to the show
[Music]
thanks for hanging with a break we're
gonna bring in natalie james
in just a few minutes
[Music]
she's
one of the democratic candidates for the
us senate in arkansas
she has a certain way of explaining act
blue that i liked uh how she explained
it so i wanted to get her take here and
then we'll cut it out and we'll post it
up on youtube so that way everyone can
go go take a look at it um so don't
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel that way you can see all those
clips and also you don't want to miss
this interview that we're talking about
with stuart rhodes estranged ex-wife our
future ex-wife yeah and and his son
tasha and dakota um adams as they are as
they are referred to now they did change
their names they talk about that in the
interview as well so don't miss that
we're hoping to announce that this
afternoon uh a time whether it be
thursday or friday again we're working
with some partners to to get this
distributed so that way we can get it
out to the masses but right now i want
to bring in i want to bring in a
democratic
uh candidate
for the senate seat in the state of
arkansas
uh
natalie james natalie how are you i am
good how are you doing oh we are doing
fantastic we're doing fantastic i you
know um we we we've talked a few times
and you go in twitter spaces i've been
going to these twitter spaces
yes yes and and i see you in there all
the time um i feel like i almost know
you it you know from the interwebs
um and we did it we did a sound test the
other day to make sure we were good but
you you did something the other day you
explained act blue and you talked about
act blue because a lot of democrats out
there and and i mean people who are
donating to democratic campaigns
they get they get kind of confused about
like donating to act blue what does that
mean who does it go to and you did such
a good job explaining i really wanted
you to come on the show and give us that
perspective um because i think a lot of
people do you think that maybe is their
hesitancy sometimes because they don't
know what act blue is
that and they don't know where it's
going and what it's for a lot of times
what i'm seeing people are like oh you
must have a lot of money to run no i'm
speaking your voice this is our voice so
it's us doing this together it's not
just me doing this i'm running to better
represent you and to make sure that you
have a voice so being a good citizen
also comes from voting and yes donating
to candidates that are going to speak
for you
right because that's important because
it's not just like money for like
television commercials like you guys
have to make sure that you got water and
food transportation um for some of your
your door knockers the people who are
helping canvas
all that stuff matters and that's like
what you need some of that money for
whether it's you or another campaign
but explain that act blue because that
that is on a tag because there's act
blue and then there's the republican one
now i i think i feel like republicans
have always understood that the voters
in this country have understood how to
donate why to donate all that kind of
stuff for years but explain to us that
act blue what it means how it goes to a
candidate i mean you can use yourself or
another candidate as an example so all
right
so with ag blue what at blue is is this
wonderful little platform app it's a
web-based can be used on your cell phone
and it's how you donate directly to a
candidate it's secure it protects your
information and it gives us the
availability to see where our money is
actually coming from who it's coming
from so we can send thank you notes and
everything else but that money is so
important because candidates like me
need it for door knocking pamphlets
things to hand out flyers make sure we
have gas to get to the different events
and get around and actually door knock
it's also extremely important so that
we're able to make sure we're amplifying
our voice in your voice so like we use
it for post-it stamps we use the
donations to pay our campaign staff we
use it to make sure that we're just
running the behind-the-scenes back
office those websites aren't free your
um emails going out that's not free
making sure the campaign has staff
phones has staff which is important
because all those correspondence and
emails that you see coming out those are
done by somebody and people are to be
paid for the work and i believe in
making sure people are paid for their
work do do and rightly so so the
importance of donating directly to act
blue and not donating to i mean there's
nothing wrong with donating to the dnc
and all of the alphabets they are
amazing they do great for the candidates
but they do the support after primaries
after they feel that that candidate is
ready and worthy the what gets us on the
map is when you make an act blue
donation and those blue donations equal
up to over a hundred thousand that lets
us know that we're a viable candidate
because it's done by you and for you as
a grassroots it's your voice so it's
another way of you just being heard
donated to act blue at blue it's
so so i was gonna ask you because i i
the touching back on the the alphabet
and them supporting you because i think
that's important to people they think oh
well you're you're a democrat you're
running for senate the dnc must be
giving you all kinds of money natalie
and what they don't understand is you're
running a primary right so the dnc isn't
going to pick and choose at this point
who they're going to support and give
money what they're doing is seeing how
you raise money right so they're seeing
how you're raising money so does the act
blue when they go to natalie james of
zack blue right or or any other
candidate and they donate to that
candidate zach blue does it go directly
to the candidate does it go to the dnc
how does that work it goes directly to
the candidate it skips the dnc they do
their own stuff like they raised 100
million dollars this last quarter which
is not a bad thing that's a good thing
no it's not it's a great thing because
they're able to spread it out all right
hopefully spread it out all over the
united states but when you have a
candidate that aligns with the issues
that align with you you want to donate
directly to them so that way you can
continue to feel their campaign so that
they can be a voice of reason a lot of
times candidates like me or candidates
are left behind and aren't heard from
it's because they don't have the
donations and the support to be able to
push them out as much as they need to
get out and be able to have their voices
be heard so at blue is a very very
instrumental tool for candidates to make
sure that we are getting out there we
have the support that we need and you
have the support that you need when you
want to go to washington when you want
state legislation when you're just
running for any office at blue is an
amazing amazing tool that goes directly
to the candidate so the candidate can
use it for other office things that are
needed such as stamps those cards
saying thank you being able to pick up
the phone bottles of water i mean
essentials exactly right you know
gatorade the normal right right because
people are working their asses off they
need a drink or two here and there and
there so exactly so the other the other
thing that you explained in the spaces
about the act blue was not just that it
goes directly to the candidates so
i think people out there can rest
assured that it's a safe way a secure
way to give to a candidate that you have
found that you like that you want to
support rather despite what republicans
may claim right about you know
right exactly republicans definitely
have it like a
targeted disinformation campaign and you
saw it throughout 2020 and 2021 which
was you know
don't trust act blue it is money's going
here right despite the fact that their
platform when red
is locking people into recurring
donations and caused trump to have to
return all of the fraudulent charges
essentially is what was done so
right well one of the largest credit
card frauds in history like right like
literally in history but we could but we
can rest assure that act blue act blue
is is completely secure it is going to
the candidate that you're giving through
through their act blue yes now explain
explain though because you you did a
really good job of explaining this
because i think this is another thing
that that people donating to democratic
campaigns fail to recognize that money
can't go up it goes down right
um so explain how that works when they
give to
a governor's race or state legislators
race or a senate race like yours explain
how that works all right so
yes at blue is secure yes goes directly
to us i go pick up my own mailbox checks
and donate it and put it into my actual
campaign account myself
so it lets me know and it makes me
extremely happy that we have support but
the best thing about act blue and what
we're able to do and what we're able to
do with your donations is when you find
a candidate that's in a congressional
race they can do it and send money down
to the constitutional races they can
send it down ticket so it's important
when you have top of the ticket
candidates that you support to support
them heavily because guess what you have
a jp you have a quorum court you have a
city director you have a school board
somebody that's running might not have
the following fee might need a little
help we're able to transfer those fees
to them to make sure that they have the
support that they need so that is the
responsibility of top of the ticket not
many people realize that and why we go
to the top of the ticket because that's
what the federal government is supposed
to do we're supposed to help be the
voice and amplify the voice of the
people and so ag blue allows us to do
that but you have to donate to those top
of the ticket actual um
actual holders which is important such
as your federal races such as your
senate race u.s senate race such as your
congressional office such as your
district offices and things like that
that way we're able to help out our
state constituents who are running for
legislators who are running for state
senate who are running for house senate
excuse me our your local house and
everything else that's what makes it so
important so we can have a very strong
ticket because if the top can't support
the middle and the bottom we won't have
a foundation and we're not going to have
a strong ticket so we want to make sure
that we have an extremely strong ticket
and we're able to allocate funds where
they need to go because it's not the
responsibility of the party it's not the
responsibility of the dnc it is the
responsibility of the people and those
running for the highest office that's
going to be your voice the united states
senate is the highest office that there
is there are a hundred people that make
decisions that directly affect you
policy and your future so you want to
make sure that you're donating to those
people and that they are representing
your voice appropriately and the best
way to do that again i know we keep
parking on donations it is to donate
because we do so much more than just
going to our campaign it feeds the
campaign for you a piece of campaign for
the ticket
well and and i think that's a good a
fantastic point that you can help those
down ballot races because um if you got
a few minutes i'd like to talk to you
about the ticket in arkansas but i'd
also i'd also like to talk to you about
um a little bit because you are a black
woman and i i know that you will have
opinions about the supreme court pick
and what the news is and all this
[ __ ] surrounding that joe biden
can't make the pick that he wants even
though he promised to make it because
that scotus nominee needs to look like
america and i believe you look like
america and i believe america that
scotus needs to look more like you i i
truly believe that and and i said
yesterday
i'm not just for joe biden picking one
black woman i think he should expand the
court and pick three or four black women
and put them on the court that would
start to fix what the problems that we
have so the first thing i want to the
first thing i want to ask is about your
ticket in arkansas and then we'll get to
the supreme court uh pick
so tell us a little bit because i know
you guys got a really diverse really
strong ticket for the democrats down
there in arkansas so anyone watching
tell us about that so they can maybe pay
attention more to that ticket down there
in arkansas okay arkansas we are blessed
to have one of the most amazing diverse
tickets that we've ever ever seen in
history before you guys have the first
opportunity to elect the first black
woman to the united states senate out of
arkansas there are currently no black
women sitting in the senate which is
scary we know what magic black women are
able to bring and we know what the
nation is needing what the nation is
wanting so we want to make sure that we
amplify those voices we have in our
gubernatorial rights excuse me i'm
skipping i forgot my congressional
people our ticket is so diverse so we
have monty hodges running for
congressional district
he's running for congressional district
one that is in northeast arkansas he's
been in legislation state legislation
for over 11 to 14 years i can't remember
the number exactly but he is amazing a
black man for the first time we have a
black man running for congressional
office for congressional district for
excuse me one
then for congressional district two we
have dr quintessa hathaway we have a
black woman this is the second time
we've had a black woman run for this
office and hopefully this time we get it
then we have congressional district
three lauren mallett hayes my dear
friend
she is a woman working mother nurse
everything on the front lines exactly
what we need to have real life
experiences here representing all of our
kansans in all of the united states then
we have congressional district 4 that's
coming up we still have a couple people
who are wanting to get in the race but
again that is a great great great start
just at the top of the ticket in the
congressional seats because currently
those seats are set by six congressional
republican members and they are
they're not indicative of us they have
not had to have the same the qualms
issues bankruptcy repossession
um
worried about how they're going to pay
rent worried about how they're going to
pay mortgage worried about how they're
going to take care of their children's
education worried about their children
and what's going on in public school
because their children aren't in public
school they're in private school because
they're afforded whatever luxuries that
they're afforded to and hand down so
when you have somebody that is not
that has not had to experience life the
way that most arkansans have had to
experience life they do not think
correctly and correlate with what's
going on with us currently none of them
can be related to majority of arkansans
or americans then for our district for
our ticket what we have is our
gubernatorial race
we have an amazing slate of candidates
we have james russell we have anthony dr
anthony blind we have dr chris jones we
have supah maize she's aapi she's a um
island pacifico that came over here
she's amazing as well we have a rocket
scientist do you hear me a rock
yes
a real one a real one
turns out they're just a rocket model
builder
a cosplay there we go right right right
but we have a real one in arkansas that
yeah that is what seat is the rocket
scientist running for governor he is
running for governor against sarah
huckabee now i'm i don't know about
y'all but sarah didn't do a good job in
washington and compared to a rocket
scientist i don't think it's rocket
science for me to figure
i would rather have somebody that knows
exactly what they're doing trusted by
nasa trusted by literally the space
stars
i would rather have that type of voice
than any other especially sarah huckabee
which is what the republicans are
offering us they have a great diverse
ticket too for them they have a bunch of
women
right right that's one step
right
at least they're at least they're there
at least they're there so speaking
speaking of diversity in women um of
course this week we know that um justice
breyer is is officially going to retire
um it seems like joe biden is going to
make his pick during the campaign joe
biden promised
it made promises that he that he would
really heavily consider and probably
more than likely pick a black woman um
if a scotus seat would come up um i
think it's a fantastic choice number one
because we've never had a black woman on
the court before i believe that that
black woman being some of the most
educated um
people in the country i i don't know
exactly what the percentages is but
like 60 some percent of all master's
degrees uh 67 percent of all doctorates
um and bachelor's degrees are black
women what's that small business yeah
small business
and and and so
the smartest the smartest most educated
group of people in this country more
more than qualified what i find funny
about it is that they're like oh you're
just picking her because she's black i'm
like do you have any idea how many
how many black women that are qualified
to be on the supreme court like like the
list is probably so long that joe biden
is gonna have to take weeks and weeks
and weeks just to figure out if the top
tier that he had already really that he
had in his mind to nominate if there's
not someone else to stick in that spot
and really there's so many qualified
black women to be on the supreme court
that no one even knows who he's gonna
pick like they're making assumptions
exactly but normally normally you're
like oh well there's gonna be this guy
who's a sweaty white ball sack and that
is exactly who they're gonna pick and
they know exactly who they're going to
pick but there's so many qualified black
women to be on this court that no one is
even i don't i don't think no one's
going to guess exactly right but they're
just all over the map so tell us your
opinion because i know you probably have
a an opinion on this
very strong opinion i mean if we have
somebody who ran for office and said
that they promised they're gonna build a
wall and didn't do it then i think we
should be able to have somebody say i
promise to elect a black woman or
nominate a black woman to the supreme
court keep in mind he's not the first um
first president to do it right right to
promise to make the promise right
exactly at least we know he's going to
follow through because that wall is
still not finished down there and right
would like to bring up so much if we're
going to talk about those empty promises
talk about the empty promises that were
already cast before with that previous
whatever we guys want to call 45. we're
going to say
exactly
that cancerous growth that's what i'm
going to call them the cancerous growth
because that's what he's done he's
infected america with the cancer of hate
and spreading that type of division and
talking about identity politics right no
we're electing the most qualified and
the most qualified on that list happen
to be a strong list of black women right
that's not our fault don't penalize us
because those are the most qualified
candidates at the time and they're
scared i mean that's what it is right
they're afraid you've got you know ted
cruz foot in the mouth saying the other
day he's like oh how can you know we
elect some women or a a woman a black
woman to be on the on uh on the bench
and it's like okay well i guess we're
gonna
yeah he said i think he said insulting
was actually right yeah yeah he said he
was insulted
by us allowing him to kiss up to
somebody who talked about his wife let's
just talk about that
right exactly
who could you possibly be talking about
yeah and it's like insulted let's talk
about you know what's coming up on right
now right we're coming up on the one
year anniversary of cancun cruz going
down to mexico on behalf of his
daughters coming in and we still have
not fixed the grid right and well let's
talk about that to be upgraded and
offended like on behalf of all texans
right right that's insulting right
exactly so let's not talk about what's
insulting offending or anything else
because him he's just an egregious
insult on the world yeah so he's an
embarrassment if there's one thing i
will say is the podcast uh he sits in an
armchair you know uh and i really are
you talking about ted cruz's yeah
he's got his uh
you know whatever he is
yeah
yeah and i'm just like oh you know he's
just an armchair senator right like
that's all he he's just that's
that's he's you know it thinks he's an
expert on something wait exactly you
know he put out a list this morning
speaking of that [ __ ] he put out a list
this morning on twitter about the uh how
to be prepared for winter and everyone's
like check
check for your check for your your
cancun plane tickets like all local
travel agents he stopped the child tax
credit which would enable people to be
able to be prepared for that that's
right right
which is inflation protection by the way
the child tax credit is inflation
protection that's that and and now i
believe that we should actually and and
i don't know what your your view is and
i'm sure i i could guess pretty quick
clearly but my view is is that we should
actually include inflation and
protection to all americans retired um
you know working families whether they
have children or not we should we should
provide inflation protection because of
what we went through with the the
coronavirus and the pandemic and how the
last [ __ ] idiot mismanaged it so
badly that you know we're trying to get
our way out of this economy and
inflation is happening because it's
heating up so fast because there's so
much demand um
but back to the back to the the scotus
pic the thing
the thing that makes me uh
i don't i don't know if it's annoyed or
laugh
it's is when they say you're making it
all about race and like look
black women are black black women are
black like that like
what how how in the hell yeah right it's
always been the same normal status quo
it has always been that and now you're
upset that it's gonna change a little
bit and it makes you uncomfortable guess
what you'll be okay they're a little
scared they're a little terrified
they're people with color in the world
you will be okay that's right i'm not
gonna bite you we're not gonna hurt you
we're gonna do what's in the best
interest of you because we are here with
you so we're going to always make sure
we're taking care of you because
inherently it takes care of us
regardless of how well you don't take
care of yourself with ivermectin and now
with the wormwood and other things like
that we're still going to take care of
you because that's what you deserve
because you are an american and you have
your freedom of rights and speech and
everything else but
allow us to do our job and allow us to
make this nation back whole again where
it needs to be it's a lot put on our
shoulders and yes we are extremely tired
of having to come in and fix the same
messes that are being messed up but this
time let us fix it so we don't have to
mess it up again
right natalie i really appreciate you
coming on and you're at the i love your
your the way you talk and um how you go
after these these these these folks i
guess we'll i you know i i'll i'll be
nice and call them folks today
i i really do appreciate you coming on
you're gonna have to come back on uh
we'll have to find um more times to have
you on i do appreciate you joining us
thank you very much we'll talk to you
very very soon yes i appreciate you now
i'm getting ready to hop on these oh one
more thing before we go where do people
go find your campaign
james for arkansas.com yes people
powered you guys are paying for that
that's why that website is still there
up and running so james for arkansas.com
you can check me out on twitter i'm very
active on twitter at james4ar you can
check me out on instagram i'm very
active on there you can check me out at
james for arkansas on tick tock yes i
have a tick tock
gabe likes to ticky talk i gotta take
that gun too shaky ducky quite quick i'm
ticklish
and then of course facebook and i'm
getting better at being active on there
but yes i greatly greatly enjoyed this i
can't wait to do it again and reach more
people because this is what it is it's
going to take us having these
uncomfortable conversations and making
them comfortable and normal so that we
can address the issues and right the
wrongs and we can grow do this democracy
thing right like actually governments
who would want to do democracy inside of
a democracy you know hey i don't know
somebody that like what was his name our
favorite person alexander hamilton maybe
you know when they kind of wrote this
constitution like
right right they wanted to do the
democracy
that's right that's right well thank you
for joining us natalie we'll talk to you
very very very soon thank you have a
good one
hard work out there hard work we'll see
you soon bye-bye thank you
vet fantastic fantastic great awesome
we gotta have her back on way way
every week maybe um she does a great job
of going after ted cruz i like that i i
would love to hear her go after tom
cotton i mean that's sad i was i wanted
is she going after his seat or the other
guy's seat so it is it is tom cotton's
seat um okay
because there's john boozman is it
boozman is it boo it's bluesman it's
bluesman that that's yeah it's boozman
yeah yeah that's that's coming out i
can't
verify but uh but yeah i i wonder i want
her to take on yeah of course you know
her opponent too who the general
election but i love right i love i love
to hear natalie you know uh tie up tom
cotton and drag him through the mud that
would be fantastic so maybe maybe maybe
next week we'll uh because tom cotton is
always doing something stupid in the
news like this guy he was saying
something dumb yesterday i don't know
what the hell was he saying yesterday he
was trending yesterday because he said
[ __ ] something dumb
oh yeah i would i would uh yeah because
she's going out it's uh it's john
boozman's seat that is up for right
re-election so if she can uh if she can
nab that seat that would be great you
know yes i'm pushing for and obviously
to have you know
some some sense of balance and reality
and intelligence
uh i mean even from the small
conversation i had with her it's like
yeah she cares about the american people
as opposed to these other
folks right
yeah but [ __ ] him he's [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
that's that's what i have to say yeah
you know